amazing
um welcome back to Street Talk unplugged
today I'm here with Professor Julian
tagelius from New York University and
also Professor Ken Stanley from openai
on co-interviewer duty can you believe
it this is the first time that we've
done anything like this I'm I'm really
really excited it's a good time to be
alive actually so um Julian um can you
introduce yourself first and then we'll
hand over to Ken to do the same yeah hi
everyone I'm Julian tagelius at New York
University where I'm an associate
professor
um in one of our several computer
science departments and um also a
co-founder of model.ai wished us AI for
games
um and well I do a lot of AI for games
and open-ended learning and things like
this I guess we'll dig deeper into this
indeed and can
um Ken Stanley and um right now I'm
leading the open end of this team at
open Ai and I know that Julian and I
have a lot of common interests so very
looking forward to this chance to to
talk
amazing well let's start proceedings
here then so um Julian you've said that
you think that games are a good test bed
for AI models and by extension actually
that if an AGI were capable of
Performing well on games then it would
be job done to a certain extent so
what's your take Julian right yeah I
said this thing that video games are
great for training generally I back when
people didn't really believe in it um uh
people thought that all games are great
and board games capture what's great
about New and intelligence and so on
um and then it turned out that it wasn't
really enough because people
um went ahead and achieved human-like
performance in these sport games with
amazing systems like deep blue alphago
and so on and still these systems
weren't really capable of doing anything
else and just playing these board games
and I was saying that well we have all
these video games and in fact they have
this very very wide design space they
um they um test a lot of different
cognitive skills in fact game designers
when they design games
um they are essentially exploring the
space of
um the space of cognitive adaptation
that we even have humans have and the
sort of sort of mapping out cognitive
skills um by finding the signs to test
our ways of thinking in new ways and
that's that's what I was saying that you
know if we try to create ages we could
play games not just one simple simple
game but games in general video games in
general in particular
um then would probably be pretty close
to what we could call AGI
fascinating but this it gets into a
really interesting philosophical
discussion though because um the task
specific skill is quite crystallized so
I I don't think anyone thinks that
that's intelligence
I think that you are right that when you
put when you put the question that way
task specific skill is not intelligence
um people will agree with you but they
also think that this is implicitly what
people think they see someone doing a
lot of things that look intelligent and
then they're like yeah this is the this
person is intelligent yes but at a core
intelligence is about being able to
rapidly build on what you know and
learning to do something more on top of
this something that sort of business and
and his new capability
and this is why you know if I um fire up
steam and downloads a random game and
start to play it
um I will probably learn to play this at
a decent level relatively fast because I
played a bunch of games
um I used to say that I play a lot of
games but not as many as I should Kiran
that I lead the game Innovation level
stuff but um someone who uh does not
have experience
um playing a lot of video games will not
be able to do that so in a sense my
somewhat General
um my intelligence in this in in this
sphere of certain video game design
conventions
um has become Higher by playing all
these games
no of course you could try to ask what
about my intelligence in general General
So my answer is that I don't believe in
that
um every notion of intelligence
um is always relative to some domain
well yeah I mean games are such a wide
spectrum of possibilities it probably in
in my view encompasses
um
like a lot of what we we think of as
sort of outside of games I mean there
are games where you have social aspects
and you know you're building a life
inside the game and it's it's not
necessarily entirely uh what what you
would do in your your whole life but it
captures a lot of what intelligence
applies to
um so it does seem to me and I know that
I I overlap with Julian a lot here with
that games have
um a lot of potential for uh learning
um high-level intelligence or even near
the human level but I'm curious
um Julian like your current thinking on
how well this uh this is playing out
with the game industry because I know
that like maybe we had a dream that like
this such a great Synergy here between
these two opportunities like gaming and
AI
um that like there's gonna be this great
partnership going forward like it would
be really cool for the games too
probably if they had really good AI
right and it's good for the AI if
there's really interesting sophisticated
games
and I think it turned out to be uh maybe
a lot more complicated but I'm curious
what you think the current status of
that is
so it's it's it's the it was a beautiful
dream wasn't it
yeah so it's a dream we shared about
like being able to develop
state-of-the-art Day animated and this
would somehow improve games and yeah I
spent the last 15 years trying to uh
that I'm partially trying to do that in
different ways and most recently through
co-founding model Dottie Ali which
um is still attempt to bring things from
research to where it would actually fit
into the game development Pipeline and
it's hard
um the parts where it's helping most is
in game testing so agents that can help
you play through aspects of game to
touch them in certain parts of
procedural content generation generating
levels in specific cases
um
but um the dream that some of us
um some of us on this call
um had a Once Upon a Time that hey
you'll be able to learn generally how
intelligent agents and these would make
the game better that is by way more
complicated because games are not
designed for that
um I like to say that most game designs
we have
um build on templates that were made
before we had uh before we had any kind
of useful AI so we had to design RPGs
and uh so role-playing Games first
person shooters
um MMOs
um possible games anything racing games
around the lack of artificial
intelligence and now that's the game
design conventions so I think that it is
really interesting both Ken and I have
worked on this um trying to design new
game games around the availability for
artificial intelligence I think this is
very very very fascinating it's very
hard it's the kind of work which you
can't get academic research money for
because this is not research and that
the gaming industry
um doesn't necessarily support because
anybody don't support research we these
are just a very strange games
um but it's true that just like take
English this thing game design putting
some kind of really clever agent in
there is in order to come and make the
game better in most cases it's just
going to make it worse
yeah I mean the game industry clearly
has some risk aversion
um to like exotic experimental things
and I mean it's understandable like I
mean it's not like some some kind of
Scandal or something like that but yet
um
yeah I mean what what is the way around
that risk aversion I'm curious because
it's it's frustrating from the like like
the opportunistic side like you see like
oh this this things could really work
together well and do something
interesting like why is there no room to
have a little playground where we could
try things like that
I think this will have to come from
Individual sort of AI practitioners
slash game designers that are well
versed enough in what modern AI can do
and have a game design sensibilities and
do these things put them out on Steam
without any expectations of actually
making lobbies and this will point the
way forward and if this sounds rough and
unfair
um that is how indie game development is
it is kind of rough enough air and most
people don't make money out of it but
it's um
uh if I was running a large video game
developer and I had to put 100 million
dollars into my next game production
knowing that if it um uh if it failed I
would um we would be out of business
um I would also be careful conservative
so so I get it you know
um it is also the problem that building
a modern game with all the water
production values um it's um is
extremely uh expensive simply so but I
mean with these big tech companies I
mean they have like not game industry
companies but other big tech companies
they have they have research wings and
things like this like right why is that
so hard for the game industry
um you know to have Labs or something
like it seems like it'd be worth the
investment like but see what could
happen make some little games that might
be might might send a point to the
Future in some way
some have but on a very small small
Escape
um we like keep both Ubisoft
um has enough Forge VA has seat
um these are smaller outfits and they
tend to be focused on how they can
support existing game Productions that
build an existing game beside
conventions
um in specific roles such as game
testing which we also do in model AI
procedural animation and so on um
there's a bit of that it's an
interesting
um the guys at the EA seat they actually
did do some interesting procedural
generation work um
um and they sort of um and they publish
it and it's pretty nice
um I like it but it's um
it's very much supporting the existing
paradigms and and I and I agree you need
to sort of if you want interesting AI to
come out there
um and and AI that makes a pass towards
um it makes progress towards AGI
whatever AGI is then you really need to
rethink these conventions
and sort of build things around like
what if you you know take to take a very
simple covered example dialogue trees in
role-playing games
no one thought that the way we should
have conversations with um
um with agents is by going navigating
down the dialogue trees
um um that was like basically the sign
of the necessity because we didn't have
any useful NLP technology back in the
80s I wouldn't have the hardware to run
it on uh we didn't have the processing
we didn't have Ram or whatever and that
became a design connection to stock and
this is now how you do it
so people like
um Nick Walton who made AI dungeon his
company I forgot what his company is
called but they anyway the AI dungeon
company they
um they are courageously trying to
Define new paradigms for that
um and uh yeah
I hope they succeed
but uh that's like one of these winter
black thing it doesn't come out of the
big game series because there's no car
they think so
um I want to come back a little bit to
this notion of intelligence because I've
got a few questions um around this and I
want to get to your ideas on super
intelligence and the intelligence
explosion as well but
um folks like pay Wang they and again by
the way the idea of having a formalism
at all is something that Ken and I have
spoken about so you you could formalize
it in in respect of an agent
um taking in percepts and having an
internal State and Performing actions in
an environment I don't know if that's
too much of a formalism or not and then
you could assess what an intelligence is
in respect of if it does the right
things in respect of an input or if it
does it in the right way because it has
the right State and and stuff like that
so but like with that framing what would
an intelligence be for you for example
um do you think Alpha zero is
intelligent
my intuitive answer is no because it's a
way to domain specific then reminding
myself that I just said that everything
is kind of domain specific which I
deeply believe my
um my revised answer would be not
particularly
um
Alpha zero is extremely limited to
acting in on one particular counter
problem it can be retrained but even
they sort of domains in which it can be
retrained um is very
um very very small and the um
retraining itself is very very expensive
so
um I don't think it can be said to be
intelligent in any meaningful sense no
um I do think that the formalisms
for lip formalisms can be inspirational
sometimes
um uh I like Shane like and Marcus
hooders um Universal intelligence
definition
perfectly because I like to point out
all the ways he can disagree with it but
it can be it has inspired us it inspired
us when we built the general video game
AI competition for example
um
um but I don't think that any form of
this will ever come will have a sort of
capture everything we mean by
intelligence in general I think there
are two manifestos sets in this field
physicists are really strange strange
because they live in a world where
formalisms make sense and where like the
mathematics in our sense is the reality
and I think that kind of thinking is um
currently Prof very much overvalued with
within artificial intelligence because
these are not the kind of entities we
deal with and the
um the sort of
the things we're trying to capture will
somehow vanish if we
formalizing damage
so back to your question
um what do I think what do I call
unintelligence
um
I think it's uh I think it's a kind of a
misposed question in terms of the word
we applied to various
organisms
um in various
um circumstances
um and it's always domain specific and
even the boundaries of the organism
matters about this being said I used to
work in tangents a lot so I would
associate it more with being able to
um being able to
survive in a large variety of
environment or like being able to have
seemingly rational industrated
environments with only only short
training time or short learning time
yeah I agree that the efficiency thing
is important because even though AIX
side or the the universal intelligence
um idea is interesting it's one of these
appeals to Infinity in the sense that
it's kind of saying well if you could do
absolutely anything then this is what it
might look like and there's this thing
called the mccorduck effect as well
which is every time that you know we we
produce something which seems
intelligence there's a chorus of people
that say that's not really intelligent
and and there's this parable of the
elephant problem as well as you say that
um we're all describing this thing um in
a particular way but we're excluding
many important aspects of the thing and
I I think one of the one of the problems
here is that like many complex phenomena
intelligence is an emergent thing and in
it it makes it impossible to describe it
succinctly
get up
it's it's also like a fork psychological
concept and it doesn't necessarily have
a true definition
um
I mean we could come up with a very
limited definition that would be um
mathematically beautiful and logically
consistent but that definition might not
be useful how do you like the term AGI
or artificial general intelligence is
that helpful
it's [ __ ]
again why is it [ __ ]
no because
um
the main reason I dislike artificial
general intelligence as a term and asked
a fee at the existence of which as the
premise of a discussion
is is because it gets a tied up with a
super intelligence um argument which I
think is strong but
extreme [ __ ] harmful [ __ ]
um but but let's start with artificial
general intelligence
um what I do like about it is the spirit
that we need to go beyond
um coming up with solutions to
individual tasks
and I think that's um inspirational
again and it has sort of guided a lot of
interesting work on trying on domain
adaptation and generalization
reinforcement learning something that
I've been working on quite a bit
recently for example and I know you I
can for example as well
um and open and learning
um but so so not easy but just behind it
um and I like that they sort of you know
push the spotlight on like we can go
beyond these very very narrow things
that are dominated AI for so long
um but the general notification general
intelligence
is always you need to always put it in
correct in into light
yeah well into quotes basically
artificial quote General unquote
intelligence because how generally can
it really be it's always the main
specific in substance
um and this is often what you sort of um
need to figure out
helps basically when you turn the
question in his head so what is natural
general intelligence then most people
would basically say that well that's
what humans have but then humans are
also very domain specific in terms of
individual humans they I mean I live
here in New York City in a nice Western
environment where I I do like
complicated things like taking the
subway to work and talking to my PhD
students all day and writing papers
um most of the tasks that humans solve
um around the world I have no idea what
to do with it you know I'm completely
worthless as the as like you know
smelting iron or harvesting wheat or
even like um sort of adjudicating
um adjudicating conflicts about like um
um land use or taxes or you know this
I'm not saying I'm particularly stupid
I'm a little bit stupid but you know I'm
not particularly stupid
um it's just that you know I know a very
small amount of things could I relearn
and do the other things yes I could
probably become a tax lawyer but that
would take me five years or something
um so how how how could you even how
could you recently say that I'm General
intelligent and that sucks then of
course like even all of humanity if
everything we know when every
environment we can survive in that's
extremely small compared to all the
tasks that you could possibly do in the
universe and all the environments that
could possibly exist or even do exist in
the universe so we have like a lack of
generality in many many ways so I don't
think artificial general intelligence
can never exist because there is no
natural general intelligence and I don't
see a reason why there would be any
I agree so a few things to unpack that
Festival I think Ben gertzel invented
the term AGI and he was exasperated with
the notion that all the AI that we're
working on now is narrow Ai and I think
basically he meant it wasn't flexible
but I agree with you yeah I I think it
was Shane Mitch
oh it okay maybe maybe yeah yeah but but
it could be a discussion about it yeah
indeed but um so I I agree with you that
all intelligence is is um in in the
context of something in a particular
domain in a particular environment
there's no such thing as completely
General uh intelligence I agree with
that but um there's also this notion uh
I know you you worked a bit with you
again schmidhuber and he had this notion
of a girdle machine a self-referential
universal Problem Solver making provably
optimal self-improvements uh and I know
you've spoken about goods and formal
remarks on an intelligence explosion
through self-improving techniques and
that this is actually what a lot of the
um you know the Nick Bostrom uh style
people uh talk about this notion that
intelligence will improve itself
um I personally don't think AGI means
self-improving intelligence but um
Francois Chalet wrote a wonderful
article about this talking about the
rate limiting steps in the environment
that would that would actually stop any
self-improvement or limit any
self-improvement but what what are your
thoughts on that
no no so I I agree with I think first
who actually has article this is really
good there
um and my thoughts on this is that um
it sort of follows from that there isn't
really
um any natural general intelligence so
it follows that there is it's it's sort
of hard to imagine what um a
self-improving artificial general
intelligence would be not as in I can't
imagine because I have no imagination
but it's not sure it even seems
self-consistent the idea so the idea so
so if you trade if you try to think out
what it would mean it was what it would
mean to be a self-improving
um artificial general intelligence
then you would need to be able to
improve yourself by rewriting your own
code that's complicated because how
would something understand its own code
well well enough but and still keep that
in representation his mind but let's say
for instance you could do that well you
only get so far by every writing World
Cup you will still need you still need
to augment all the code that this bit so
because you have networking code your
operating system code and probably the
hardware that he built something told me
to Hardware you need an extremely
extremely huge Global Supply Chain you
need to sort of generate and design
better ships so you need to have better
machines that can build them so you need
better lasers and you need better
um mining for the component that goes
into these and so when you need better
Logistics to transport things and so on
basically getting what
it would what being sort of you know
um self-improving at an unlimited scale
but what it means is that you sort of
need to improve the whole world economy
so I would say that the only reasonable
way you could think about a
self-improving organism would be if you
saw the civilization as we know it as an
organism that is that is self-improving
now they say goodbye this might actually
be the case
so there is a version of the super
intelligence argument which I believe
may be true to some extent but that but
in that version all seven billions of us
humans are kind of part of the Machinery
of the self-improvement empty
um and and then you can see people
saying aha well there is an egi in there
somehow that controls all of this like
sits in a box somewhere in a server and
sort of end sort of um sort of uh
controls all of us like marionettes or
something to which I would say that
sounds dangerously like all kinds of um
disproven and unlikely conspiracy
theories
um that's just not how the world and
it's fundamentally distribute the
decision making uh actually works
um so
the agle and so the super intelligence
argument it's in almost all versions
almost ridiculous except the version
where you talk about it on civilization
scale
but even then it's really hard to figure
out what's in Egypt
what do you think though um like if you
if you put aside the jargon in like
these different terminologies like what
do you think we should be aspiring
towards it's like what is the North Star
Holy Grail thing
now that's a really interesting question
um
I think I think we should Aspire towards
gradual generalization gradually more
General
um capabilities and it's fine to come up
with somewhat contrived and weird bench
works for this
um so maybe the um May becoming
Correctional use cases I like these
ideas of working on like developing
embodied robots that could basically be
home nurses and take care of a person
who is bedridden in every conceivable
way
um such as you know cooking dinner
um cleaning the carpets
um
watering the plants um taking care of
the pets and whatever you may need to do
in in a home and that's great because
that is a very very wide range of um of
skills you need to do there
um
even though all the skills
please note you know all the skills here
or the kind of skills that we selected
or created
um as as a human civilization you know
um why is the opening a door is a hard
scale for a robot but it's an easier
schedule should be because we made all
the doors so that we use could easily
open them so it's still very domain
limited but it's it's like a reasonable
challenge
no so that's a good challenge you know
many challenges like that personally
um I want an AI that can um play every
game on the App Store
um or steam Library
um reasonably well and I think that
would be a very great achievement
um and it would teach us a lot
um this is not how I write things in
grant funding proposals because
um other people get roll the rights like
why would anyone want to do that
um how is this helping Humanity I think
it's helping you manage by teaching
about us a lot about how
um and how to build quote intelligent
unquote machines
um another big vision is that I want to
build um environments that we can call
them games we can call them
entertainment environments experience
environments that are self created that
you can go into a simulated open world
and you can walk in any direction and
the game will precept you with
experiences with present you think say
you're playing Grand Theft Auto and you
sort of walk in any direction you get
like new cities
um new um
and people in there we're driving
um cars you've never seen before and you
know they have like relationships you
never heard about before they have like
new narratives
um and this is all sort of um
there to basically serve you in a sense
that the system is trying to probe what
you like what it what you find
interesting what experiences you have
not had yet had but it thinks you would
actually like to have and this would be
interesting because it would Advance the
state of the art to both like building
building worlds and building narratives
building uh game mechanics building all
these things but it also very much is
the m
sort of
um
it it would very much sort of
um a in advance of the state of doing
our DN systems that understand humans
and look at what we do then what we say
and try to get inside our minds and
models
yeah it's interesting because there's
there's kind of two sides to what you're
describing I think was one is kind of a
more
um mechanical operations like the nurse
who takes care of the patient or
something like that the PC has certain
articulation skills that it needs to
learn like to to get the food or to give
a bath or something like that and then
there's like very creative like I mean
creating a world or something like that
um where like that's like not just good
for games I mean it's you could have
like you know
um artificial intelligence like
literally participating in culture
um and I guess um you know like making
things for us in the real world too
um I'm curious about your your feeling
about those two things is that like do
you think they're related to each other
or that um there's one more important to
you than the other
yeah I mean there's a difference between
important for Humanity and important for
me yeah
I'll have to and all humorous aside you
know that I had to recognize this this
distinction
um I think I am personally I mean I come
from a family of artists and this is how
I grew up I never grew up with like you
know
um I was never told to always think
about the best Humanity I was I grew up
with people who literally painted for a
living and when they couldn't make a
living out of painting they would sort
of take a day job and sort of make money
from that somehow so um over all the way
grumbling about wanting to get back to
their to the real work
um so
um
I'm very interested in
machines and methods that can create and
they can create together with us
um both and autonomously
um in in response to us and how big it
would also together with us I think the
history of the art is very much a
history of technological development
because like
um artists driven so much
um
um so much development in ways of
manipulating colors and materials and
representing reality and so on and I
think that see in the end new art styles
have also been driven not only by like
trying to
um depict what people see or sort of in
some depict or narrate what people see
around themselves but also new
technologies that make this art possible
from like new methods for painting and
sculpting your colors and so on to new
methods of writing and sort of um and
and of course like digital art like like
games or so on so I'm very interested in
that because I think it's intrinsically
interesting and this is
this is what contributes to our culture
in a sense um it helps us understand
ourselves and gives us better and richer
lives
now I forgot what was the original
question
uh well uh well I um I mean I think you
you answered it pretty well but I guess
I was curious about the um the same kind
of dichotomy between these like very
practical like nurse robot and then like
create a level like which is like so
open-ended and there's so many like
creative aspects to that oh just how
those those signify together
I think there are several ways that
you'd fight together
um these on the sort of um on some of
the abstract level every problem so all
chromosome is great and everyone
um
basically in in in I think I think I can
certainly say that everyone practices
some creativity in their life even if
what you're doing is being a home care
nurse
um you will find problems that you need
to solve creatively this wasn't going to
book you know how am I going to deal
with that um ah the cat sleeps on the
medicines or whatever you know then you
have to figure out something about that
um but there's also a more down to earth
or or closer to the actual current
research front doorway which um
is that and I know you've been working a
lot with Afghan for example that we can
use creativity to create problems that
um our agents can learn to solve so
generating levels in its great in itself
but is also great because it can help us
test and retrain reinforcement learning
agents for example
so um something that has been discovered
by a bunch of people over the last few
years is that deep reinforcement
learning tends to overfit in a pretty
bad way you know
um reinforcement learning agents tend to
not only be able to fit into a
particular game they cannot play that
game nothing else but also to a
particular level or seek particular
levels of a particular sequence and a
particular sort of you know screen
resolution angle
um a sort of frame rate everything if
every little part and you change any any
record of this and you you get like um
random behavior and
um and and all and and for all the
thoughts you just had about like oh I
saw these deep neural networks playing
the Satori games it's really smart look
it can play phone or Montezuma's Revenge
or something you know and then in that
sort of um you uh you change just a tiny
bit of thing you see it collapse
um now you wonder how you learn
something slightly more General slightly
more General game playing skills and I
think part of that
a very important part of that is
generating parts of the game as you go
along maybe not only the level but also
the rules of the game and the represent
the graphic of representation and you
can also vary a ton of different things
so in a sense this is like the um
data augmentation which people have been
talking about and practicing in machine
learning for a very very long time but
take into new limits
um how to sort of do this
and one thing that I am very interested
in at the moment and I know you've been
working again before
um is exactly what kind of levels do we
need to generate
what's it what's interesting in
generating here
um for example do we want to generate
levels that discriminate well between
different agents run do we want to
generate levels that are hurt how hard
um do you want to generate levels that
have a particular set of challenges in a
particular order what are interesting
points to
um what are interesting points to to
vary and so on so these these are things
I'm working on
um
pretty much as we speak
um but yeah and then this is one way so
to get back to the question this is one
way how very mundane concerns of solving
particular tasks intersects with
creativity and automatic creativity I
really wanted to unpack exactly what we
mean by things like creativity and and
open-endedness and subjectivity and
ambiguity and and all of that but let's
just quickly do the reinforcement
learning thing now because I want to
eventually contrast that to some of the
open-ended methods that uh Ken introduce
me to by the way absolutely open my open
my eyes when I discovered Ken's book and
research but um you've you've spoken
about the overfitting of deep
reinforcement learning I actually um
made a video on my other channel about
Alex Urban's article uh deep
reinforcement learning doesn't work yet
you probably read that one before but um
oh yeah yeah so but you know you've said
that oh is it is it because we're
training on the testing set is it
because the training set is small and
homogeneous is it because our models are
too large is it because the input
representation favors learning specific
strategies or or something else and you
were just saying well if only we could
generate data as we go along and and I'm
thinking it's because neural networks
are locality sensitive hashing tables so
why do you think these reinforcement
learning algorithms are you know you
said memorizing the the environment
because it's the easy thing to do
um
is I agree with you that
neural networks
in many instances were pretty much like
and specifically if we talk about
reinforcement learning they often work
more or less like local sensitive
hashing
um and um and uh but why do they do this
because that's the easy thing to learn
it's a path of least resistance in a
sense
um
this actually plays into a
bigger critique
um of
is
is it good that gradient descent is such
a dominant Paradigm
um because it's currently grading to
send this D dominant
um
I've written before but I've had some
troubles articulating as well as I would
want to about how I think that
um the implied greediness is not very
good for learning the kind of complex
representations that we probably need to
learn
um I'm not saying it's impossible but I
think that's um I mean I use a lot of
modern deep learning and what I do but
I'm a basically instant
um I come originally more often to
evolutionary computation side of things
um and I still think that the path of
making larger
um stochastic changes
um and letting them play out to be
evaluated over a longer time has the
advantage that um
you can you can learn things that
gradient descent would struggle to learn
because the way descent would always be
pushed around by the data points
essentially
now so that this is one reason
um in general
um reinforcement learning methods that
we know and love well that we know and
use currently
um are extremely prone to just taking
the simplest way
um or the simplest way to sort of you
know get to them and get a good
performance and this is not this is not
a controversial
um sort of uh point of view this is
generally accepted and uh and knowing
this the problem is
um
I mean the the the the extreme variation
of the conditions that you wonder you
want to get through to
um sort of to proceed to Regeneration is
there basically because you need to
explicitly vary everything you don't
want to reinforcement learning to learn
to use as a crutch
um
and um
in in a sense the relevant question is
um is not really what it does it overfit
why does it learn this very specific
Solutions is how can you make it ever do
anything else
it's sick because it doesn't come
naturally like doing to grain Central
green
um you will naturally sort of move
towards the same the simplest solution
inside and that is almost always some
extreme form of fitting
um
your question was also about like if
there are other reasons for this right
well maybe it would just quickly
meditate on that so I guess I'm trying
to tease apart in my mind because one
one aspect of it is the shortcut rule
which is that you get exactly what you
optimize for at the cost of everything
else
and um these models are trained
monolithically with a single objective
and and Ken opened my eyes to this idea
of you know a system with a panoplay of
objectives has no objective at all
um but but I'm I'm still thinking in in
my mind that the way all neural network
architectures work is you've got the MLP
back end which is the hash table and
then there's a whole bunch of
architectures for for doing the
diffusion of information with successive
equivariant layers so you're kind of
spreading the information out into those
buckets
so with that in mind how could it do
anything other than memorize the
environments maybe we should bring in
the net hack challenge so apparently the
reason why that worked uh sorry didn't
work for reinforcement learning and did
work for symbolic methods is because it
wasn't possible to memorize the
environment because the environment was
different every time
yeah it when I saw the network challenge
I was like this is a great challenge one
of my PhD students was really interested
in working on it and um that we haven't
really put any real effort into that yet
we may still do but I immediately
thought that no way we're gonna get to
see a reinforcement learning doing well
on this um not anytime soon
um it's not
the environment is also not represented
in a way that the neural network would
like
um it's it's uh naturally not such a
representation
um and of course the variation me makes
it really hard to do so yes I sort of um
this is very much a symbolic friendly
environment
um which is why it's good I hope that
people keep working on it now nothing I
can is about to say that uh well
actually my team go ahead I wish you
could say that
um actually I wanted to ask you guys
because I wasn't sure if I I only read a
little bit about that but my
understanding was that neither approach
did well like the symbolic approach just
was better but that wasn't exactly good
or it was far from good
so it's just sort of like wow we don't
really is that true is that pretty much
accurate like there's really not a good
well it was
well again I think it comes back to what
we were saying at the beginning about
what is intelligence so the symbolic
approach basically was a representation
of the game as if you'd coded it up you
know with classes and and methods and so
on so is that really intelligent if you
can if you can represent
um if you can take a game and basically
represent it so well so you can keep it
in memory and try accepting things you
basically use the game which is old
forward model
um this is almost always
um the best way to play it
um it's just not many games or so
computation demanding that you can
easily do that but yeah we don't worry
illegal challenge back in 2009 when you
put it online we thought that this is
going to be a great challenge so people
have been able to you know work hard on
this and so on and then um Robin
baumgarten of Liberia College
basically solved it um within the first
few weeks but doing exactly this using
the game
um has its own representation and then
just pledge and
well classic AI methods like planning
um with combined with sort of fantastic
relation or just like extremely good in
many cases uh the question is can you
use the right Zone representation
so so could we contrast this um because
we were just getting to the contrast
between the monolithic reinforcement
learning approaches where there's a
single reward versus and and Ken would
say that's keeping all of your eggs in
one basket versus
um approaches that utilize diversity
preservation so what do we get there
I think the quality diversity Paradigm
is extremely powerful and will
eventually eat all of AI well great for
more or less
um
some inequality diversity you may need
to be doing an optimization task you may
also not being doing optimization tasks
but crucially your
exploring the space and find trying to
find diversity and along some measures
in original research you simply have a
distance measure in about the leaves you
have um several behavioral descriptors
so you can call that um
we often these days we often call that
just called them lectures a lot more
metrics um there's a terminological
confusion
um and and you want to find solutions
that are just like evenly spread out
along these measures
um and and but and you may also want to
find solutions that are good and those
measures in almost every problem where
you're trying to optimize something
you're not actually looking for the
OnePlus solution you're looking for a
large amount of different solutions that
differ along some Dimensions you care
about
um and then you want to pick even in
cases we just want one solution you
probably want to do anything you want to
have a large
um a little more diversity in the
process to make sure you actually find
the last solution
um and I think this realization has yet
to diffuse uh sort of
um widely into the AI and machine
Learning Community
um
is not there yet
but I think it's crucially a um
I mean we've seen use cases for it
everywhere we see use cases for it in
like if you're trying to learn
um a policy to play a game well you
probably want many different policies
and you won't assume it's still on them
we want to combine them build some
Sanders uh and you want to be able to
adaptively rapidly switch for one to
another or something
um if you want like content generators
you probably want several difference you
can get like a wide variety of content
styles could use if you want
um
models that help you predict who to hire
you probably want different ones so you
can explore the trade-offs and so on for
like almost every case where you can
imagine you want machine learning
optimization you probably want to use a
quality diversity method instead luckily
there's a lot of development going on
um in sort of taking the core IDs behind
things like mobile instruction map leads
and a combat ending then with um because
these are essentially at the core
they're like classic evolutionary
algorithms but working in diversity
working diversity has has the main the
main thing to do but combining that with
modern gradient-based methods to sort of
get the best of both Works
um we we we developed we developed
something called The covariance Matrix
rotation map Elites that is like a
modern Evolution strategy
um and within the mapping structure and
we're just like seeing that this is like
the defaulting we apply to basically
everything the recruitment we see first
of all now
do you um you you previously commented
about
um you know the contrast between
gradient based and well it's not
necessarily what you'd call evolutionary
but it's kind of like knocking something
out of its own like intentionally which
is tends to be now what gradients do
um do you think that like when I mean in
light of what you just said about
quality diversity that
is um is that a relevant distinction
still do you think like or is it like
any it doesn't really matter what the
underlying kind of optimization method
is you can you can just use a different
gradient let's say uh to push it one way
or another because because you're
talking about using you know gradient
methods with these quality diversity
algorithms
yeah so grading methods obviously have
uh many advantages and in particular
they're efficient
um but I do think and and I think you
can combine them with the quality
diversity thinking that make love to
wears that are partially grade based or
integrated based in many ways
um
but
um
but they sort of um but I do think
there's still an advantage to sort of
doing the undirected mutation at various
steps like the learning algorithms of
the future will almost certainly
um
take place or sort of operate in
multiple different scales the song scan
where you do large algorithmutation in
subscale where you do a gradient descent
search and and you also throughout this
trying to
um with like maintain some kind of
diversity
um and you may have one or several or
many objectives and you may have the
number of like dimensions of of variants
um that you can might be important New
Dimensions may be collapsed as you
search New Dimensions may appear as you
search
um and this may be partially interactive
with with with human users you may call
Delta T the difference between this
thingy over here and this thing over
there isn't this is an interesting
difference keep that in mind as you
continue searching for example but I
think that just like under a mutation
definitely it will payroll
um in there so this is waiting for all
these like inside the coalesce I think
the there's also movement from
from the other side so to speak from the
side of people who I haven't yet sort of
been converted to the products and
diversity
in particular when it comes to
reinforcement learning in learning um in
um
finding leaks and sort of you know
Finding setups or pools of teams of the
collaborators or like adversaries like
Alpha store in Alpha stores I think is
called mix well you have like Clinics of
different collaborators and the new
collaborative a new agent is really or a
different adversaries new agent needs to
be tested against all of these for
example
um this by the way are classic IDs from
co-revolution professional convolution
collaborative convolution that have sort
of been rediscovered um
over the time so I think that many
streams of thoughts are sort of you know
pushing towards this
this realization I recommend folks read
Ken's book as well so when I read Ken's
book and I learned all about this notion
of deception in search spaces and the
false Compass
um that absolutely changed my perception
on on everything because I I now realize
that you know um you need to keep your
options uh open but and I wanted to just
touch on one other thing as well so um
I'm quite interested in this notion of
empiricism versus rationalism and one of
our guests Walid Saba he he rails
against deep Landing because he he cites
uh chomsky's Poverty of stimulus
argument you know which is basically
that you know kids must have native
cognitive templates because they can't
possibly learn Enough by the time
they're four years old
um but not not only that um there's also
a notion that you've raised so if you
look at Einstein's theory of relativity
for example it's kind of provable that
you can't derive that from data you need
to have some kind of higher level uh
cognition and then you made a really
interesting move which I didn't quite
understand so maybe can explain it now
you kind of said that with these
evolutionary type algorithms that's akin
to the rationalist type thinking as
opposed to the empiricist type thinking
don't understand that
no I'm not sure I understood it myself
but I still think there's something
there
um I think that gradient descent is in
realism to fundamentally pushed around
by the data
um data points appear and the causality
is that the data point
um pushes your hypothesis if you want to
use the terminology or your uh or your
model in some in some direction and
you're very much similar to how it
classic it appears as you the same state
are supposed to literally make
Impressions on your um on your mind and
this is what's happening in in the
gradient descent based deep learning
evolutionary computation is based on the
random change in its most pure form
um now and and the random change does
that happens at another level it happens
kind of at the hypothesis level you're
changing a random hypothesis and then
you're testing it the fitness evaluation
is the testing of your hypothesis
now what people
um have raised against this I think Jeff
Clune at some point basically said
just as you said him like I don't
understand this really because
hypothesis formation isn't trend that is
correct I put the information isn't
typically random
sometimes it is sometimes people are
like you know this doesn't make sense so
let's trade a trade anyway that's my
favorite kind of science this is a
stupid idea so that's right
um but um but it points to that there
are other things you know evolutionary
computation you can have very many
different forms of mutation in there and
like throughout the history of
evolutionary computation people have
tried all kinds of different things for
example
um what very often happens in real life
hypothesis formation is pattern matching
like um I have seen another theory that
looks like this so I'm going to take the
pattern of this Theory and overlay it on
what I think in this field and now I
have a new hypothesis and then I'll go
out and do this so this could be like a
form of mutation that does pattern match
um
and this is entirely viable and I think
this is the kind of a more rationalist
conception of search yeah um so say
you're sort of
um you have okay this gets harder to
sort of
apply intuitively to the neural network
search base because neural network
weights don't really mean anything but
um you could imagine that you have like
a particular sort of say you're sort of
evolving a decision tree you might you
you may know that there's a particular
kind of tree structure you've seen in
another decision tree this hypothesis
formed this way and you may want to sort
of just apply this to some to some part
of your own tree and this becomes
um
this becomes a um a hypothesis then you
try this by Fitness testing it
um and any it's not the Perfect Analogy
um but I do think there's something
there and it helps underscore what are
the limitations of um gradient um
gradient descents like pure gradient
design search it is I'm much more much
more certain of like the connection
between where I feel much better about
connection between classic empiricism
and
um in gradient descent and then I am at
the connection between fractionalism or
critical rationalism and evolution but I
think there's a way of making damage on
you started off by talking about
um well you actually invoked Randomness
and it's not random is it and this is
something that um Ken's work fascinates
me as well because Ken has this notion
of interestingness and the problem is
when we Define creativity and you know
we're getting back to that definition
problem there is no definition right
what do we mean when when we talk about
open-endedness and creativity and I I
think Ken was trying to formalize it in
the sense of accumulating information
you know like in Natural Evolution
there's an arrow of complexity
would you would you agree with a
formalism like that or or how would you
define it
still
is there any rules completed
what okay can you so when you're
abandoning objectives paper um I think
you said that you were one of the first
researchers in the ml world to
um almost validate or at least take
seriously this idea in biology that
there's this era of complexity of of
increasing information in Natural
Evolution yeah I think um I think the
argument is is about you know this idea
that um
as opposed to following the gradient
chords improving performance which you
normally do in machine learning uh we
could be trying to just increase the
amount of information
in the system which is a different kind
of I guess you could call gradient but
it's a different kind of thing that
you'd be searching for and so I guess
you could look at divergent searches or
novelty driven searches or
interestingness driven searches or
things like this as effectively doing
that like they basically increase
information in some way like and if you
if you look at Evolution over eons I
guess you could see that it's uncovering
more information about so the question
about what I guess about about nature in
some sense like about all the things you
can do you can fly like you can walk you
can ambley you can move through water
you can do photosynthesis you can think
like all these things so like this is
like an index of possibilities opened up
by physics
um and they're being like kind of
unveiled because of the this um this
kind of search that isn't necessarily
objectively driven and so um that kind
of an era of complexity I think that
kind of sense of like let's let's get
more and more abilities cataloged in
this like archive in some way and it's
it's both population and individual so
like as an individuals like we know all
the planets in the solar system and
things like this like this is definitely
like an accumulation information
relative to our ancestors so so
something like that
yeah yeah that's something so that makes
a lot of sense and I do think that you
know
um as we work in open-ended systems one
thing that's really crucial here is that
we
um think about the environment as you um
that that you the thing that's
developing in an open-ended system
um isn't just be agent which is like a
kind of sort of arbitrary somewhat
dormitory sort of um uh
solar system
really is sort of defined entity but
like the whole ecosystem because the
reason why we can do things that seem so
intelligent is that we build this whole
civilization that enables us to do all
these things that seem so intelligent
like um
um and we have like this extreme freedom
of action it's a branching factor of a
human living in modern world is insane
um
um and the reason we could build this
complicated civilization is the extreme
complexity of life on Earth which then
depended on previous life on Earth and
so on so in that sense and that you sort
of implicitly creating an oracle of
complexity
um through all the living things that
makes a lot of sense now is there
that is the thing I reacted to is that
is there also an error of complexity
in terms of individual organisms uh
having that knowledge that organisms
somewhat arbitrary boundary but um and
that that's less certain you know are we
more complex and you know are we more
complex than other creatures Are we more
complex than than our ancestors
um our grandfathers or whatever
um that's not obvious
um maybe maybe not
um is it is it necessarily true probably
not but yeah
um maybe what these points too is how
important it is to think of intelligence
capability on a population level well
I'm curious like when you like like
getting to individuals just to
understand your Viewpoint like um I
think it some lineages it's I agree that
it's pretty ambiguous like uh hasn't it
has complexity increased or not like we
could debate about it but in the in the
human lineage like you're saying that um
it's not clear for example that like
humans are more complex than flatworms
or just is that because like to me it
seems like it's pretty reasonable to
think that but it would you would you
contest that
well
I could find I'm sure I could find some
measure by which it is false you know
that it's like yeast genome is like
extremely complex
um and then you sort of you know then
you look at it still you just just yeast
you know and I like bread and everything
but still
um it's uh so that but but that's kind
of a stupid measure of complexity
um
so would I contest it I would qualify it
I would say like you know that we we are
certainly more complex in Dimensions we
care about then they basically all their
ancestors other other measures of
complexity by which we are not more
contexts and maybe worse probably
um can I will put them right now no
because uh yeah that's uh maybe because
I'm interested I'm interested in the
kind of inhuman kind of things mainly
this is a sincerely objection I I was
just to me it makes more sense that
there's an error complexity on a
population or ecosystem level which I
think that definitely is and um there's
a bit more confused on the individual
organism now
um
it relates to the to the issue of like
the definition of complexity it's
someone because it's not well defined
here and um so I'm just going with sort
of intuitive like I feel more complex
than a flatworm but yeah it's true if
you play with the definition you can it
gets confusing but yeah I don't know if
that that's that useful to play with it
no
no
true
um
I think you talk to scores to Media
Thunder scores that um
I'm also looking for complexity I'm also
looking when I sort of if we create like
an agent that um either uh it sort of
plays a game will generate a game level
to not getting things I typically do I'm
also looking for complexity I wanted to
do things that I couldn't have predicted
it would do yeah I wanted to well uh
that's the capital Plex we are looking
for but in many cases when we're looking
at general intelligence I feel
on an intellectual level though I'm not
sure I practice it emotion looking more
at the population or ecosystem level how
can you find like a
um
a wide variety of organisms with with
that work together to go to create
something complex
that that I think that's really
interesting because like it is true that
a lot of a lot of AI today or modern
machine learning is focused on an
individual
like there's just one thing that's
getting better
um but this um this this notion of a
population there's a lot of a lot of
power in it I think and um yeah I wonder
if if you could could say a little more
like what what's the difference like why
would why do you think a population
um adds something important
um than than just optimizing one thing
I think a population in particular when
it's heterogeneous uh one is not all the
same
oh
it's interesting because
we because the different the population
or an ecosystem because a different
organisms create the conditions
to for each other to be intelligent
so intelligent is always intelligence is
always relative to a domain and um and
all organizations we know of are like
adapted to a particular domain where we
sort of you know we are intelligent
because of the world we build now you
have an ecosystem of different organisms
behaving in some environment they can
sort of create that for each other
um
I don't know how to do this and I don't
know whether anyone really has good
ideas of how to do this there's there's
a long history of a life experiments
like
and so on and there's a bunch of like
more graphic and adap worlds and so on
um
these all
are kind of primitive even what they
actually were able to do and the and and
kind of um
unsophisticated inter methods um now
some will probably come and sort of hit
me over the head with like you know
actually hear this fantastic experiment
that didn't think of but I think that's
a big sort of uncut potential in
particular as we work um open-ended
open-ended learning um which is
definitely one of my big interests
um we're still looking at like you know
here's one single environment going
about in one one single one single agent
in one single environment um and
um and there's like a population of
Agents but they're all trying to solve
the same task or like you know they all
have the same affordances and so on
I think there's a wide open field of
things we have not explored out there
we're not explored
with in the united depth I think um one
thing that really fascinates me is
um a lot of the interesting phenomena
happens at a different level a different
rung of the emergence ladder if that
makes sense and I'm starting to see this
everywhere like even at work I'm
building a code review platform and at
the low level the metrics are obvious uh
I know Ken talks about the the tyranny
of metrics by the way but you know it's
how many code reviews that has an
engineer done how many customer
Engineers do I have it's easy and then I
start going up the levels of abstraction
I'm talking to the senior leaders and
now I'm starting to use much more
abstract language like vertical
information flows and trusts and
Engineering culture and all of a sudden
it's impossible for me to quantify and
if I do I'm making it up and it's the
same thing you're talking about these
populations scale phenomena that
happened now so I've got all of these
intelligent agents they're doing things
and and I can try and because now I've
got a meta optimization problem right so
so I want to encourage interesting
phenomena in the emergent scale so I
might say well this type of thing is
interesting I want more of that but I'm
I'm kind of I'm reaching because I don't
know how to describe it I don't know
either it's a it's uh it it I mean one
way to phrases is that doing the camp of
research we kind of outlining here it
might be hard to get it into new ribs
because
um
you don't necessarily easily have a
graph where the number goes up and The
Benchmark to beat
not saying that every paper in Europe is
like this but hey let's say that this is
the norm right I mean I think one of
their one of their characteristic maybe
you can point to that that kind of
separates some like population from just
individual is sort of specialization
versus generalization like I think
population driven algorithms are
implicitly are more about specialization
a lot of the time because like each
member of the population you want them
to be doing some different thing so
they're kind of becoming Specialists but
I think there's a huge amount of
generalization snobbery kind of within
machine learning like we're looking for
the ultimate generalist all the time
it's like you get it to do all the tasks
you can possibly do and then throw more
in and the data set just gets bigger and
we're all we're impressed with that the
population implies I feel like
something's in spirit different because
it's more just like actually I want to
see a lot of different things and like
hyper specializations to all kinds of
exotic things that like probably the
generals won't do because it's basically
all it cares about is being General
um yeah what do you think do you think
that's also maybe part of uh why
populations are appealous
and and this comes down to like the
focus on like the particular level of
abstraction or the level of agency that
we have a
um able distance level of the agent I've
done this is what we care about so you
want generous that level of agent but
maybe you want a general you should
generate that level of the ecosystem or
population if one interesting thing is
like if we don't get like very
boring so-called machine learning boring
but useful machine learning the stuff
that the stuff that keeps winning all
the kaggle competitions um uh especially
with structured data is um this Ensemble
methods such as xgboost and
interestingly they solve problems by
splitting splitting and not having a
single agent or single model having a
bunch of different models enforcing
diversity through a very different way
than requires diversity methods
and by changing data set and I combine
them together so in a sense it is the
population that is solving the problem
um so it's my convergent light of
thinking Jillian it's it's such an honor
I've really really enjoyed this
conversation thank you so much and and
Ken as well yeah oh me too it's like
great yeah this was great thank you
thank you for giving me the opportunity
uh to be here